mon invité n'a pas connu l'Algérie
française puisqu'elle est née peu après
son indépendance mais l'engagement de
son père dans l'os a sans doute
déterminé beaucoup de choses dans sa vie
peut-être même son propre engagement en
politique
[Musique]
bonjour Michel Tabaro bonjour alors
l'engagement chez vous c'est d'abord une
histoire de famille avec votre père
Robert Tabaro qui a mené un combat
politique pour l'Algérie française un
combat qui a pris une forme radicale
puisqu'il a été l'un des dirigeants de
l'OAS l'organisation de l'armée secrète
est-ce que vous auriez fait de la
politique si votre père était resté le
champion de boxe qu'il a été puis le
vendeur de pièces détachées de voiture
probablement pas parce que j'imagine que
nous serions restés en Algérie si il
avait pas mené ce combat et
qui était très attachés à la France qui
a souhaité protéger les Pieds-Noirs les
harkis de tout ce qui se passait pendant
cette guerre terrible entre entre 54 et
62 à souhaiter s'engager il avait un
amour pour la France et son amour pour
la France absolument qu'il a mené ce
combat et puis aussi au nom d'une
certaine injustice parce que lorsqu'on
en 58 le général de Gaulle vous annonce
que vous êtes en Algérie et que
l'Algérie doit rester française être
obligé de partir quatre ans après comme
les militaires des hommes remarquables
comme Elie de loi de Saint-Marc qui
avait été un résistant avait été à
bukenwald avait été ensuite en Indochine
n'a pas accepté comme beaucoup de
militaires la raison du putsch alors
c'est vrai qu'on connaît mal cette
histoire mais c'est un sentiment de
trahison terrible et surtout il y avait
malheureusement des exactions et il
fallait protéger les les pieds noir et
papa c'est beaucoup battu et nous
inculqué
de la parole donnée et puis ce lien
aussi indéfectible entre entre les
Pieds-Noirs entre les harkis entre
l'Algérie aussi et alors ce combat
politique de votre père c'est un peu
toute votre famille qui en a payé le
prix parce que quand l'Algérie est
devenu indépendante vous n'avez pas vu
enfin votre famille n'a pas pu retourner
en France parce que votre père était
condamné en France pour terrorisme et
donc vous êtes réfugiés en Espagne à
Alicante c'est là que que vous êtes né
que vous avez grandi loin de la France
pendant presque 6 ans quel rapport
est-ce qu'on entretient avec son pays
quand il y a un tel contentieux entre
son pays et sa famille c'était pas un
contentieux avec la France c'était un
contentieux avec un pouvoir politique je
peux pas vous dire que de Gaulle était
particulièrement apprécié à la à la
table lorsque nous nous évoquions
l'Algérie française
bien sûr comme une blessure mais pas
avec le pays loin de là la blessure elle
a été énorme parce que quelque part
j'imagine lorsque vous avez des enfants
et que vous avez envie d'aller voilà
leur montrer l'endroit où vous avez vécu
tout ce qui est fait leur histoire avoir
la possibilité de retourner dans son
département dans une autre commune et
tout ça c'est merveilleux mais pour nous
c'était quelque chose d'interdit et d'un
autre côté il a fallu recréer une vie
qui ressemblait à la France en Espagne
créer l'école française c'est ce que mon
père a fait avec les pieds-noirs qui
étaient installé là-bas créer un journal
pour pouvoir informer et bien les
Pieds-Noirs de ce qui était la vie mais
vous même par exemple à 5 ans vous avez
dû être hospitalisé en France votre père
a pas pu vous accompagner et aller à
votre chevet à l'hôpital absolument ça a
été fâché contre la France écoutez à ce
moment là enfin je le comprenais très
bien je pense qu'on a été mûr très tôt
parce que on parlait très librement de
tout ça avec avec nos parents ma mère
m'a accompagné donc j'ai eu cette
hospitalisation pour un problème de
d'abcès aux poumon et donc j'ai été
soignée en France et mon père voilà
enfin il était
loin de moi mais avec en prenant des
nouvelles régulièrement mais je le
comprenais tout à fait et j'ai pas j'ai
pas souffert de cette absence parce que
je la comprenais quelque part malgré mes
5 ans donc tous les membres de l'os sont
finis par être gracier administier votre
famille est donc rentré en France et
s'est installé au Cannet dans les
Alpes-Maritimes votre père est ensuite
devenu une figure importante de la
communauté pied-noir qui était sur place
assez assez nombreuses et vous-même en
1983 je crois que vous avez à peine 20
ans vous êtes élu adjointe au maire du
Cannet 5 ans plus tard c'est votre petit
frère qui lui est élu conseiller
municipal à Cannes encore plus jeune lui
là à peine 18 ans à l'époque il est
aujourd'hui sénateur
ce double engagement en politique est-ce
que c'était une façon un peu de laver
l'honneur de la famille de venger votre
père de prendre une revanche sur
l'histoire bien entendu c'est quelque
chose qui est en moi qui est très fort
et je comprends tellement et je partage
cette cette douleur qui est celle des
pieds-noirs d'abord d'avoir été trahi
ensuite d'avoir été accueilli dans des
conditions assez difficiles parce qu'en
métropole on avait la vision simplement
que de ces militaires qui partaient se
battre et l'Algérie c'était pesant il y
a eu beaucoup de guerres et il y a
peut-être pas eu la compassion que les
Pieds-Noirs auraient pu attendre après
ce drame terrible qui a touché plus d'un
million de personnes qui après plusieurs
années de guerre se sont retrouvés un
petit peu éclaté dans dans un pays qu'il
ne connaissait pas qui était leur mère
patrie puisque c'était la métropole mais
il n'avait jamais vécu en France quand
vous vous engagez en politique c'est
pourquoi c'est parce que votre père vous
dit il faut y aller pas du tout mon père
j'étais favorable et un soutien de de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing en 80 donc je
fais la campagne mon père
qui faisait il était actif en politique
adjointe
et donc je m'engage pour la campagne de
80 et ensuite je suis tellement déçue et
affecté par par la victoire de François
Mitterrand que je décide de prendre ma
carte au Parti républicain qui était la
droite mongoliste de l'époque et c'est
comme ça qu'on me propose de rentrer au
conseil municipal du Cannet et que je
deviens adjoint en mer et ensuite mère
du Cannet alors votre histoire familiale
liée à l'Algérie française elle a aussi
resurgi à l'Assemblée en 2005 ce jour-là
enfin à l'époque les députés débattaient
de la suppression d'un article de loi
qui est volé qui évoquait le rôle
positif de la colonisation vous avez
pris la parole dans l'hémicycle c'était
un peu au nom de tous les vôtres d'une
certaine façon on va le revoir en images
la France coloniale a permis d'éradiquer
a permis d'éradiquer
dévastatrice grâce au traitement
dispensés par les médecins militaires
les Français d'outre-mer ont permis la
fertilisation de terres inculte et
marécageuse la réalisation
d'infrastructures que les Algériens
utilisent encore aujourd'hui
la France a posé les jalons de la
modernité en Algérie en lui donnant les
moyens d'exploiter les richesses
naturelles de son sous-sol
votre tolérance
alors on le voit à vos propos avaient
déjà fait réagir une partie de
l'hémicycle à l'époque vous comprenez
aujourd'hui que ça puisse choquer de
défendre le rôle positif de la
colonisation écoutez moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est qu'on ne comprenne
pas donc vous restez je reste alors la
colonisation le départ
aujourd'hui
je suis hors de moi lorsque je relis et
lorsque j'entends les propos d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2017
considérant la colonisation un crime
contre l'humanité autant je ne souhaite
pas qu'on aille coloniser
qui que ce soit d'autre aujourd'hui
autant il faut bien comprendre notre
histoire c'est à dire que l'Algérie a
connu la France pendant 130 ans les
personnes qui étaient nées là-bas mon
père était là-bas depuis plus de trois
générations donc il se levait tous les
matins avec le drapeau français dans les
écoles ont chanté la Marseillaise
l'anxiété des blessures je les entends
tout à fait mais ce que je veux dire ce
qui s'est passé en
ne justifie pas qu'on
est ce sentiment de culpabilité
vis-à-vis de la France on voit
aujourd'hui tout ça avec notre regard
d'aujourd'hui mais lorsque vous voyez et
bien tous les beaucoup de pays ont eu
des colonies ont apporté des choses
positives des choses qui l'était moins
mais la France a quand même en Algérie
et on le voit bien malheureusement
l'Algérie 60 ans après et dans un
contexte compliqué politiquement elle
elle vit avec une dictature qui n'a pas
permis à ce peuple exceptionnel avec
lequel on a des liens de fraternité
d'amitié de se développer comme il le
fallait mais la France a laissé des
hôpitaux elle essaie des routes à
soigner maman était infirmière elle a
soigné autant des musulmans que des que
des Européens il y avait pas ce problème
qui il a peut-être été réel chez
certains mais la grande majorité des
pieds-noirs vous savez Albert Camus a
dit quelque chose de très beau il a dit
ma famille et Dieu sait qu'il était
dans les milieux
universitaires et dans les milieux
gauchistes qu'ils pouvaient fréquenter
parfois attaquer là-dessus il l'a
défendu à chaque fois en disant que que
sa famille n'avait opprimé personne et
il faut bien réaliser que la grande
majorité des pieds-noirs se sont
comportés en frères avec avec les
Algériens et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
qui fait que les arcs les harkis ont été
des des combattants aux côtés de des
Français parce que et bien il y avait ce
lien très fort entre les Français et les
arabes on va passer à tout autre chose à
présent notre quiz vous avez droit à une
version spéciale pour ce quiz vous avez
passé plus de 20 ans à l'Assemblée
est-ce que vous êtes du genre à dire
c'était mieux avant c'était différent
est-ce que le cumul des mandats c'était
mieux avant absolument je vous ai très
très favorable au cumul des mandats je
pense que ça nous donnait une grande
liberté au niveau du gouvernement
lorsqu'on est dans la majorité et au
niveau de l'opposition
la vie du gouvernement vis-à-vis de
notre famille politique je pense que
vous allez me répondre ancrage
territorial ancrage territorial
absolument parce qu'en cage territorial
c'est-à-dire lorsque vous avez la
légitimité lorsque vous êtes voilà
quelqu'un de d'implanter quelque part
c'est pas le parti ou c'est pas le
gouvernement qui va vous dicter les
choses vous jouez collectif bien entendu
mais vous savez et le gouvernement et le
parti savent très bien que vous êtes
enraciné vous siégé donc à l'Assemblée
depuis 2002 vous avez connu vous le
disiez la majorité et l'opposition
est-ce que vous diriez que la vie
politique à l'Assemblée c'était mieux
avant alors je vous disais donc pour moi
c'est différent j'ai vécu des périodes
passionnantes avec
la période où Jean-François Copé était
présidente de groupe on faisait de la
coproduction législative c'est à dire
qu'on avait des parlementaires qui
étaient totalement impliqués et qui
arrivait à pousser les lignes au niveau
du gouvernement ça d'ailleurs été le cas
pour un texte comme la burqa ou vraiment
c'est le Parlement qui a porté ça et qui
a un peu obligé le gouvernement de vous
trouvez que ça ça fait défaut
aujourd'hui
depuis
ce mandat on revit quelque chose de
positif je dirais pour l'assemblée c'est
le fait d'avoir une opposition qui
arrive à se faire entendre du fait de la
majorité de la majorité relative par
contre ce qui me pose problème
aujourd'hui c'est c'est l'attitude de
certains qui sont dans la victime qui
sont dans la provocation qui sont dans
le globale
est assez épouvantable vous avez été la
première femme élue présidente de la
commission des affaires culturelles en
2009 est-ce que la place des femmes en
politique c'est quand même pas mieux
aujourd'hui qu'avant oui probablement
mais je n'ai jamais vécu comme comme un
problème
on a trois fois plus aujourd'hui très
peu aussi de femmes mères lorsque j'ai
été Luère à 32 ans mais je dois dire que
j'ai jamais souffert de ça parce que
voilà bon j'ai mes convictions mais mon
engagement et je peux pas dire qu'en
étant une femme j'ai voilà mais je suis
ravie que les femmes puissent accéder à
toutes les fonctions politiques et
professionnelles très vite juste le mot
de la fin 40 ans bientôt d’engagement
dans la vie publique c'est quoi le
secret de votre longévité à écouter je
pense que je continue à faire de la
politique dans la proximité voilà
j'adore je finis ma semaine à Paris
j'arriver rapidement au Cannet je dans
ma circonscription je vais voir mes
électeurs je suis en contact et en lien
permanent je pense que c'est ce qui me
fait durer c'est ce qui me fait en tout
cas comprendre la France dans laquelle
on vit aujourd'hui et essayer de la
défendre au mieux merci beaucoup Michel
Tabareau d'être venu vous confier dans
la politique et moi merci
[Musique]